nos dicen la parábola dada por igual a
3x cuadrada menos 6x más 1 y la recta
dada porque menos x más 1 igual a 0 es
tan gráfica das y puedes ver sus
gráficas la parábola está en rojo
mientras que la recta en azul y lo
primero que nos preguntan es uno de los
puntos de intersección es claramente
identificable a partir de la gráfica
cuál es ese punto y nos piden que lo
pongamos en este espacio
de hecho esto es una captura de pantalla
de un ejercicio de khan academy donde
puedo escribir si lo está realizando en
khan academy tendrás que introducir la
respuesta
pausa el vídeo e intenta ver si puedes
encontrar la respuesta de la primera
parte
bien nos dicen que uno de los puntos de
intersección es claramente identificable
a partir de la gráfica y podemos
observar dos puntos de intersección este
y este de aquí el segundo es claramente
identificable ya que de forma visible en
la cuadrícula tenemos el punto de
intersección en el valor de x igualados
y de igual a uno nuestro punto de
intersección es el punto 2,1 déjame
escribirlo 2,1
y es interesante pensar que además de
que los puntos de intersección están en
las gráficas de ambas curvas significa
que satisfacen ambas ecuaciones son la
solución a ambas ecuaciones y después
nos preguntan encuentra el otro punto de
intersección tu respuesta debe de ser
exacta es decir nos piden encontrar este
otro punto de intersección para ello
intentaremos resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones y es interesante porque
observa es un sistema de ecuaciones
donde una de sus ecuaciones no es lineal
es una ecuación cuadrática así que
veamos cómo podemos resolver este
sistema
primero escribiré las ecuaciones tengo
en rojo a ye igual a 3 x cuadrada menos
6 x + 1
y nuestra siguiente ecuación en azul es
100 x 1 igual a 0 una forma de
trabajarlas y esta es una forma de
trabajar cualquier sistema de ecuaciones
es usando sustitución si puedo escribir
esta segunda ecuación lineal en términos
de james es decir resolver para james
entonces podría sustituir ayer en mi
primera ecuación en ecuación cuadrática
y con esto resolver para x la forma más
sencilla de resolver para ella de la
segunda ecuación es sumar x de ambos
lados y después restar uno de ambos
lados
con esto nos quedará que bien y el resto
del lado izquierdo se cancela es igual a
x menos 1
ahora podemos sustituir x 1 en lugar de
que entonces me queda x 1 es igual a 3 x
cuadrada menos 6 x + 1
después queremos un cero en uno de los
lados de esta ecuación así que voy a
restar x de ambos lados y sumar uno de
ambos lados que obtenemos en el lado
izquierdo obtenemos 0 y en el lado
derecho me queda 3x cuadrada menos 7 x +
2 así que esto es igual a 0
ahora podemos intentar factorizar existe
un factor que sea obvio es decir existen
dos números que al multiplicarse
resulten en el producto de 2 y 3
si esto no te parece familiar puedes
revisar los videos de factorización por
agrupación en khan academy por otra
parte quiero que la suma de estos
números se iguala menos 7 de hecho menos
6 y menos 1 funcionan por lo tanto lo
que puedo hacer es reescribir todo esto
como 0 es igual a 3x cuadrada y en lugar
de menos 7 escribiremos menos 6x menos x
y por último tengo mi más 2 lo único que
estamos haciendo es una factorización
por agrupación para aquellos que no se
sientan familiarizados con esta técnica
también podréis utilizar la fórmula
cuadrática
entonces tengo que hacer es igual am y
si el grupo los dos primeros términos
pueden factorizar de ellos un 3 x y me
quedara que 3x multiplica a x menos 2
mientras que de los segundos dos
términos puede factorizar menos 1 así me
quedara que menos 1 multiplica a x menos
2 y ahora puedo factorizar a x2 si
factor hizo a x2 nos quedara que 0 es
igual a x menos dos por tres x menos uno
por lo tanto la solución será la
situación donde algunos de estos dos sea
igual a cero ya sea que x menos 12 igual
a 0
3 x menos uno sea igual a cero
el valor donde x2 es igual a 0 es cuando
x es igual a 2
si 3x menos uno es igual a cero podemos
sumar uno de ambos lados y obtenemos que
3x es igual a 1 después si dividimos
todo entre 3 obtengo que x es igual a un
tercio
muy bien ya habíamos visto la solución
donde x es igual a 2 es este punto de
aquí incluso lo escribimos es el punto 2
1 ahora encontramos el valor de x de la
otra solución x vale un tercio el valor
de x es de un tercio y necesitamos
resolver para el valor de jeff ahora
bien
el valor de ye es el valor
correspondiente que obtenemos al
sustituir este valor de x en cualquiera
de las dos ecuaciones y quiero enfocarme
en la ecuación más simple de las dos así
que queremos saber cuánto más leyes
cuando x es igual a un tercio en esta
ecuación podríamos usar la de arriba
pero esta es incluso más sencilla ya que
queremos resolver para ella y aquí lo
tenemos si sustituimos a x igual a un
tercio obtenemos que que es igual a un
tercio menos uno de lo que nos queda que
es igual a menos dos tercios
y parece que estamos en lo correcto que
es igual a menos dos tercios así que
este es el punto un tercio coma menos
dos tercios y lo hemos logrado